mental health in the black community
that has been a problem for decades
a lot of that plays into the stigma
about mental health and the reason why
people are not going to get to help this
necessary
barbershops are a safe place for young
men of color barbers are only people in
our life that we allow to get close
proximity with us with a razor
we realize that partners become our
friends and that's really important
because I can use that same space to
work with barbers to talk about mental
health
[Music]
my name is Lorenzo Lewis and I am the
founder and CEO of the confessed project
the confessed project is a national
grassroots movement that is geared
around building a dialogue with mental
health for young men of color I had a
lot of problems as a young person my
mother was incarcerated when I was born
into this world and losing my dad at the
age of 10 I didn't know how to deal with
it I would go to this beauty salon every
day after school and was a barber
there's and I never forget you know a
lot of the nurturing care that I got
from him really empowered me to want to
do better really want to empower me to
do good in school I realize that I'm not
the only one struggling a suicide is the
third leading cause of death for a young
men of color between the ages of 18 and
24 and a lot of this plays into
communities where there are a lot of
violence and toxic masculinity
so the barber shop was a perfect place
to start the confess'd project
I'm walking to a barbershop and and
accidentally if I could have a moment of
their time and then that moment turns
into an educational session thank you
all for being here today I think the
most important part is why I really came
in today it really show that I can
exhibit to you all how we can break
through our pain and how they're partly
there being our purpose our goal is to
not train barbers to be mental health
experts but the training to be mental
health advocates we're training them
with the skills of active listening
communication validation to not be
judgmental to be sensitive with language
so that their clients can be able to
open up and possibly go and get some
help and treatment that may be necessary
I've always been feeling in a depressed
state and I never knew why no I still
don't know why to be completely honest
was the first time I've ever heard a
black man talk about his struggles of
mental health there his emotions with
feeling like he's low for the like he's
in that hold that he can't get out of
and that's a feeling that I felt before
growing up it was a feeling that I felt
often there's a feeling that I was
feeling in that time that I came to here
I thought it was very powerful seeing
black men coming together hugging and
sharing that valuable moment together
and you could see it in their eyes and
an emotion
[Music]
since starting to confess project we
have now expanded to nine US cities
across the southern and Midwest region
it's really important to keep that
momentum going we realize that you still
have a lot of work to do it is one of
those things where we have to create
leaders and build a generation of
leaders so that they can be sustained
and also go out and help many more
community members that we may not reach
what I specifically love about my job is
that I get to work with that side of me
that I wasn't able to get that same help
with and help young men of color to
really thrive and to really become the
best version of who they are
[Music]